[موسيقى]
احييكم واهلا بكم الى نشره التاسعه هذا
المساء نبدا كالعاده بابرز العناوين
و
بمقابله خاصه للعربيه
مسارات
وخوفا من نقط ترسانتها العسكريه جيوش
اوروبيه ترفض ارسال ليوبارد لاوكرانيا
ظاهره مخيفه في مدارس البنات بايران هجمات
تسميم متعمده للطالبات والصحه تكشف هناك
من يريد حظر تعليم الفتيات
وعلى غرار كندا وامريكا البرلمان الاوروبي
يحضر تطبيق تيك توك على هواتف موظفي خوفا
من الاختراقات
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم نبدا مشاهدينا من المقابله
الخاصه التي اجرتها العربيه مع رئيس
الوزراء الاوكراني الذي طالب بضغوط دوليه
على ايران للتوقف عن تقديم دعم عسكري
لروسيا خاصه فيما يتعلق بالمسيرات
الايرانيه وقال في هذه المقابله ان روسيا
تستخدم هذه المسيرات منذ اكثر من سته اشهر
لاستهداف البنيه التحتيه المدنيه
والمدنيين
تتطلب الحرب الحديثه بالتاكيد مقاربات
عاليه التقنيه وللاسف وجدت روسيا دعما في
شخص ايران فيما يتعلق بتزويد القوات
الروسيه بطائرات بدون طيار وللاسف تستخدم
روسيا هذه الطائرات بدون الطيار ضد البنيه
التحتيه المدنيه وضد المدنيين قبل
مقابلاتنا بقليل قصفت اربعه عشره طائره
ايرانيه بدون طيار البنيه التحتيه المدنيه
وقتل شخص واحد واصيب اربعه اليوم وهذا
مستمر منذ اكثر من نصف عام والمئات وربما
الالاف من الطائرات بدون الطيار الايرانيه
تقصف ايضا البنيه التحتيه المدنيه
والمدنيين في اوكرانيا وبطبيعه الحال
الاجراءات المضاده ضد هذه الطائرات بدون
طيار واستخدام نظائرها زادت بشكل كبير
بنسبه لاوكرانيا من حيث مواجهه هذا
العدوان غير المبرر لكنه عدوان وحشي لا
سيما ضد السكان المدنيين ضد المبادئ
الانسانيه وبالطبع دعم اوكرانيا من حيث
تصدير المعدات يمكن ان تصبح الطائرات بدون
طيار نقطه تحول حاسمه لذلك نحن ممتنون
لشركائنا وسنكون ممتنين للسعوديه التي
ستقدم مثل هذا الدعم لاوكرانيا لزياده
الضغط على ايران بحيث تتوقف ايران عن
امداد روسيا بالمعدات ذات الصله والطائرات
بدون طيار وهذه العمليه ستكون عاملا حاسما
ورئيسيا لمنع ايران من تصدير الصواريخ الى
روسيا التي ستستخدمها بالتاكيد لقتل
المدنيين الاوكرانيين
رئيس الوزراء
الاوكراني على غزوه الروسي لبلاده بالتسبب
في ازمه غذاء عالميه وقال للعربيه ان
روسيا حاصرت الموانئ الاوكرانيه ما ادى
لوقف الصادرات الحبوب عن عدد كبير من دول
العالم
شكرا يا واحده من اكبر مصدري المنتجات
الغذائيه خاصه حبوب الذره وللاسف ان
الحصار الذي فرضه الروس على الموانئ
البحريه الاوكرانيه الى واحده من اكبر
الزمات الغذاء وهي ازمه الغذاء التي يمكن
ان تكون لها اثار ماساويه حقا في العديد
من البلدان الافريقيه والعديد من دول
الشرق الاوسط
لحسن الحظ تمكنا من تنظيم ممرات اللوجستيه
عبر اوروبا وايضا عبر موانئ الدانوب وايضا
تنظيم ممر حبوب بشكل عام خلال هذا العام
من الحرب صدرت اوكرانيا نحو 50 مليون طن
من منتجات الحبوب الغذائيه منها 21 مليون
طن عبر البحر الاسود رغم الحصار وصل الروس
اغلاق جزء كبير من موانئنا فقط ثلاثه
موانئ كانت تعمل لتصدير الحبوب فقط ثلاث
سفن في اليوم سمح لها الروس بالعبور عبر
النقاط المتفق عليها في تركيا واستطعنا
تصدير حوالي 50 مليون طن اذا استقر الوضع
في سوق المواد الغذائيه بالطبع الان في
شهر مارس ستكون المرحله المقبله تنتهي
بالماء البارد ونطلب من جميع الشركاء خلق
ضغط مناسب على روسيا من اجل الاستمرار في
ممر الحبوب حتى لا يتسبب في المستقبل
بازمه الحبوب والغذاء
المقابله كامله مع رئيس وزراء اوكرانيا
اسمها
الاختيار ستتابعونها والتي تحدث عنها طبعا
عن دعم دول الخليج الانساني والاقتصاديه
لاوكرانيا وتحدث فيها ايضا عن العقوبات
الجديده التي تقترحها بلاده على روسيا
سنتابعها كامله غدا في الرابعه عصرا
بتوقيت جرينتش السابعه بتوقيت السعوديه
وايضا في مقابله للعربيه خاصه قال نائب
رئيس البرلمان الاوكراني ان وثيقه السلام
التي اعلن عنها الرئيس زيلينسكي بسيطه
وواضحه تتضمن انسحاب روسيا من اراضينا
بشكل كامل وعوده حدودنا الى ما قبل 1991
وثيقه السلام التي اعلن عنها الرئيس
زلينسكي اقرت في قمه مجموعه دول العشرين
نحن في اوكرانيا نرى انها قمه التسعه عشره
دوله لان روسيا لا تستحق ان تكون بينها
وثيقه السلام بسيطه وتستند الى مبادئ
واضحه مثلا انسحاب روسيا من اراضينا وعوده
قواتها الى موسكو من دون باس والقرم ايضا
وعوده حدودنا الى ما قبل
1991 موقف اوكرانيا واضح وقوي ويدعمه
الاوكرانيون نحن واضحون لا نريد اي تسويه
مع روسيا على حساب سيادتنا بعد كل ما
عانيناه من ويلات الحرب ومختلف الاسلحه
التي استخدمتها روسيا لتدمير بلدنا
وهذا خبر عسل رويتر ستتحدث وتنقل عن مصدر
بان اوكرانيا طلبت من الامم المتحده ومن
تركيا بدء مفاوضات تمديد اتفاق تصدير
الحبو اذا اوكرانيا طلبت من الامم المتحده
ومن تركيا بدا مفاوضات تمديد اتفاق تصدير
الحبوب وهذا حسب مصدر لرؤيه الرسم اما
غربيا مشاهدينا قالت لجنه القوات المسلحه
في الكونكرس الامريكيه ان تخصيصا 100
مليار دولار من المساعدات العسكريه
لاوكرانيا امر غير مسبوق مضيفه انه يجب
مراقبه مصير الاسلحه التي ترسل لاوكرانيا
عن كثافه واعتبرت لجنه القوات المسلحه في
الكونجرس انه يجب ارسال اسلحه لاوكرانيا
دون الخوف من تصعيد بوتين في المقابل قال
البنتاجون للجنه القوات المسلحه في
الكونجرس انه لم يسجل بل لم يسجل ضياعه اي
اسلحه
من اوكرانيا
مضيفا انه لم يلاحظ اي انحراف في استخدام
اسلحتهم في اوكرانيا
قبل ذلك انتقد وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
انطوني بلينكن خطه الصين للسلام في
اوكرانيا وقال انه لا يمكن لها ان تدعم
روسيا ثم تقدم مقترح سلام في نفس الوقت
لا يمكن للصين ان تربح من الوجهين حينما
نتحدث عن العدوان الروسي على اوكرانيا لا
يمكن ان تقدم مقترح سلام بيد بينما تغذي
شراره العدوان الذي بدات روسيا باليد
الاخرى لذا اتمنى ان تاخذ الصين ما نقوله
بجديه وما تقوله الدول الاخرى حول العالم
وان تبتعد عن اي دعم لروسيا
[موسيقى]
والان مشاهدينا سنتوقف مع تطورات
الميدانيه للحرب في اوكرانيا حيث تمكن
مقاتل وفاجنر من السيطره على اطراف مدينه
باخمه شمالا وجنوبا وايضا شرقا كما نتابع
هنا على هذه الخريطه ايضا استطاعت الوصول
الى مركز المدينه هنا ايضا
والمعارك الرئيسيه هي الان في بخمه يبدو
بانهابع الان الان من الممكن ان نتابع
ماذا يجري في بخمه هنا مشاهدينا تتركز كل
المعارك وقت طويل مر على روسيا لم تحرز اي
تقدم باي منطقه في اوكرانيا الان هي تركز
على هنا تحاول
ان تطوق هذه المنطقه من كافه الجوانب من
الشمال هناك حي ستوبكي تحاول مستميته ان
تصل اليه وايضا من الجنوب هناك حي سباشكا
ايضا المعارك تدور هناك وتتقدم القوات
الاوكرانيه ونعود ونذكر بانه من يقاتل في
هذه المنطقه بالذات في بخمت هم قوات فاجنر
هي التي تتقدم في هذه المنطقه هنا ايضا
تشتد كل المعارك في هذه المناطق بالذات
ولكن مشاهدينا هناك امر جدا مهم تحاول
قوات باجنر ان تمنعه وهو هذا الخط هذا
الخط الذي سنتبعه سويا من هنا الى ما يسمى
بمنطقه شاذو فيار هذه المنطقه بالذات
تحاول ان قوات فاجنر تحاول ان تقطع الطريق
هذه لماذا لان الامدادات من اوكرانيا
لبخمت تصل عبر هذه او هذا الطريق اذا
اردنا ان نكملها هكذا تحاول ان تقطع هذه
الطريق حتى لا تصل الى القوات الاوكرانيه
في بخنوت وبالتالي هي تستطيع ان تطوق هذه
المنطقه وتسيطر عليها حتى ان وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه تقول بانها تقريبا تبعد كيلومترين
الى حد ما عن هذه الاحياء التي تحدثنا
عنها
هنا في بخمه الاوكرانيه تقترب اطول واشرس
معركه في الحرب من نهايتها حيث تقول
المعلومات وصور القادمه من هناك ان الخناق
يضيق على المقاومين الاوكران ضيق يقابله
اصرار على الصمود حتى النهايه
المدينه الصغيره بحجمها الكبيره في اسمها
وموقعها الاستراتيجي اصبحت ايقونه في
الحرب الدائره منذ عام ورمزيه للانتصار
لمن يسيطر عليها بعد اشهر من الجمود على
طول الجبهات المشتعله شرقا وجنوبا
تعتبر بخموت اخر القلاع الاوكرانيه في
اقليم دونيتسك شرقي اوكرانيا وهدفا رئيسيا
للرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين حيث سيمنح
الاستيلاء عليها موسكو انتصار النادرا بعد
عده اشهر من النكسات موقع المدينه يشكل
نقطه التقاء استراتيجيه بين منطقتي
تشكلان القلب الصناعي الاوكراني اضافه
لكونها تعتبر نقطه انطلاق جديده للجيش
الروسي باتجاه العمق الاوكراني واكبر
مدينتين في المنطقه هما كراماتورس كواس
تقول اخر المعلومات ان قوات فاجنر دخلت
احياء باخموت الشرقيه والوسطى فيما تزال
الاحياء الشماليه بيد الجيش الاوكراني
لتتحول المعركه الى حرب شوارع بين الطرفين
كيف لم تنفي صعوبه الوضع في المدينه شبه
المحاصره لكنها تصر وجيشها على الصمود رغم
شراسه المعارك وموقفها المعقد
يمكن لجميع ان يرى اننا نواجه صعوبه في
هذا القسم الامامي العدو يهاجم باستمرار
في مجموعات صغيره وكبيره فاحيانا يواصلون
القصف المدفعي واليوم التالي يشنون هجمات
المشاه انه امر صعب لكن اولادنا يستمرون
في الصمود بارضهم
بين ترقب سقوط وقدره على الصمود فالاكيد
ان القتال في باخمت اصبح معركه كسر عظم
بين الطرفين معركه قد تكون انعطافه جديده
لحرب بدات لتوها عامها الثاني
متابعه لكل هذه التطورات الميدانيه
وابرز احمد باكاتو مفرد العربيه من موسكو
كاتيا
رائد الاغبر مراسل العربيه لنبدا معك رائد
حيث تتركز المعارك في هذه المنطقه بالذات
ما هي ابرز التطورات واين وصلت تقدم لقوات
فاكتر التي تحاول تطويق الى حد ما
ميسون مساء الخير بالفعل يعني حي ستوبكي
الذي ذكرتيه في المنطقه الشماليه من باخ
مدخله قوات فاغنر واظهرت فيديوهات لتجول
المقاتلين في هذا الحي وهو يبعد عده
كيلومترات عن اطراف المدينه وما زالت
تتقدم القوات الخاصه الروسيه من جميع
النواحي الشرقيه والجنوبيه والشماليه في
العمق لمدينه كييف عفوا مدينه
باخمه يعني متوجهه الى مركز المدينه ربما
ما زال الجيش الاوكراني يدافع عن المدينه
بانتظار المعونات او الدعم العسكري الذي
وعدت به الدول الغربيه والولايات المتحده
لان الدبابات
الالمانيه والامريكيه اذا وصلت الى منطقه
دمباس ربما تغير في مسار المعارك في تلك
المنطقه وحتى المدافع عند الجانب
الاوكراني نقص بالذخيره حسب ما صرح
العسكريون الاوكرانيون ربما ان القصف
المتبادل هنا في مقاطعه في قلب العاصمه
يعني انخفضت وتييرته رغم سقوط القذائف
يعني 24 ساعه الماضيه اقل من 200 قذيفه
وصاروخ ذهب ضحيتها ثلاثه اشخاص منهم اطفال
لكن ما زال عند الاوكرانيين ما يعني
يمارسون به
المعارك وما يضغطون به على جانب الروسي
لكن ما زالت قوات فاجنر تتقدم في المحاور
كما ذكرتي محور باخموت خصيصا وتحاول توسيع
الطوق من الناحيه الشماليه نحو الغرب ومن
الناحيه الجنوبيه نحو الغرب وذلك لاغلاق
الطوق الكامل وللسيطره على الطريق السريع
طريق شوسوفيار اذا انقطع هذا الطريق فعلا
يعني تنفقد او يعني
ستشح الذخيره بين يدي المقاتلين
الاوكرانيين وربما سيكونون محاصرون في ذلك
المحور ساذهب الان الى زميلنا احمد باجاتو
من وجهه النظر الاوكرانيه والمعلومات
الاوكرانيه وخاصه من وزاره الدفاع ما هي
التطورات في هذه الجبهه احمد وفي المناطق
التي ايضا ما زالت تشتعل فيها الاشتباكات
نعم ميسون اهلا بك وبالزملاء يعني بالفعل
ضربات صاروخيه وهجمات جويه بصوره مستمره
على الجبهات الاوكرانيه المختلفه لا سيما
الجبهات الشرقيه وتحديدا منطقه ومديرها
المختلفه
وكذلك ضخمه الحديث الان عن ان الفاكنار
تهاجم بالقوات الاكثر جهزيه لها مجموعات
صغيره
مجموعات صغيره باعداد كبيره في اكثر من
جهه تحاول
تطويق القوات الاوكرانيه متواجده بصوره
كامله حتى الان لم تنجح
الدفاع الاوكرانيه تتحدث عنها تكبد القوات
الروسيه خسائر كبيره من 600 الى الف قتيل
يوميا في صفوف هذه القوات المهاجره هذه
القوات المدعومه او تحقق تقدمات مدعومه
بالطيران الحربيه والطيران المسير لكن
المدفعيه الاوكرانيه تحاول التصدي لها
وكذلك الطيران المسيره الاوكراني الذي
يحاول استهداف اماكن تجمعات القوات
الروسيه هذا الامر ربما يعني يجعلنا ننتقل
الى الشيء الاهم هو ان القياده العسكريه
والسياسيه هنا تركز على ضروره ان يكون
هناك كسر لهيمنه الروسيه على سماء
اوكرانيا لانها الطيران الحربي يمارس دورا
كبيرا في التقدم القوات الروسيه في ضخمه
وغيرها من الاماكن لذلك المطالبات مستمره
بضروره يكون هناك دعم بطيران او كذلك
طيران اخر اوروبي او غيره هذه وايضا باظمه
رادار متطوره لم تخلو ايضا الجبهات الاخرى
والمناطق الاخرى من ضربات جويه وصاروخيه
كخرسون التي تم استهدافها بضربات صاروخيه
اليوم اسرع مقتل شخصين واصابه عدد اخر
الحديث ايضا هناك ضغط على سكاني المحلي في
منطقه زبروجيا التي تقع بها المحطه
النوويه وتسريح تسريح الذي تم العمال
الذين يعملون في هذه المحطه الذين كانوا
لديهم خبره كافيه ويتم توظيف الان عمال
الاخرين روس ليس لديهم خبره ودرا يه
التعامل مع هذه
المحطه الهامه كل هذه الامور يعني تقول
نعم يعني سينتهي وقتي ولكن اريد ايضا ان
استفيد من وجودك في كافه لتطلعنا ولو
بايجاز على ابرز المواقف اليوم على
المبادره الصينيه التي تم الحديث عنها
بالامس
مرحبا ميسون بالفعل الكريم اليوم على
لساني متحدثه ديمتري بيسكوف كان قد علق
مجددا على الخطا الصينيه خطه السلام حول
اوكرانيا قالت طبعا ان هذه الخطه هي
تتوافق مع النهج الروسي وبالاخص حول منزل
الامن وبالتحديد هنا حول عوده روسيا الى
معاهده او اتفاق ستارتين نيو الذي قام
الرئيس الروسي اليوم بتوقيع قانون تعليقه
تعليق موسكو او مشاركه موسكو فيه طبعا
روسيا تعتبر هذه الخطه بانها بان اي خطه
سلام ستقدم حول اوكرانيا فهي ترحب بها
ولكن هذه الخطه تحتاج الى
دراسه مطوله وتحليل مطول لان الازمه
الاوكرانيه هي ليست فقط مؤلفه من طرفين
ولكن هناك اطراف عده وبالتالي اي خطه
تحتاج الى دراسه كبيره وبالتالي من بعدها
يمكن
الذهاب والعوده الى
طاوله المفاوضات مع الجانب الاوكراني طبعا
ان كان هناك اشاره من الجانب الاوكراني
للقبول هذه الخطه طبعا من ناحيه من ناحيه
اخرى شارع روسي طبعا ينظر رواد الخبراء
كانوا يتحدثوا عن ان هذه المبادره التي
قدمتها الصين هي اشاره واضحه على ان على
ولاء الصين الى روسيا اولا وثانيا الصين
تنتظر ردا او اشاره من الجانب
الامريكي ومن الجانب الاوكراني في حال
طبعا رفض جانبان هذه الخطه هذا دليل على
ان هناك تصرف حاد الجانب بالنسبه الى
الازمه من قبل واشنطن وبالتالي سيكون لدى
الصين الحق الكامل بدعم روسيا بشكل مفتوح
بهذه العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في
اوكرانيا ميسو شكرا لك كاتيا بمراسله
العربيه كنت معنا من موسكو على هذه
المعلومات كما نشكر زميلنا من كاز احمد
بكاتو مفاده العربيه ومن دونيات رائد
الاخبار مراسل العربيه شكرا لكم
في ملفات الحرب اوكرانيا ايضا افادت صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز ان دولا اوروبيه تواجه
مشكلات في توفير الدبابات التي تعهدت
بتقديمها لاوكرانيا وتعليقا على ذلك قال
مسؤولون غربيون ان توفير دبابات لاوكرانيا
ليس سهلا كالاعلان عنه
افادت ايضا نقلا عن مسؤولين المان جيوش
اوروبيه رفضت ارسال ليوبارد لاوكرانيا
بسبب حاجتها لها ودول اخرى اكتشفت ان
الدبابات الموجوده في مستودعاتها لا تعمل
او تفتقر الى قطع الغيار
نقلت وكاله رويترز عن مسؤول امريكي قوله
ان شركه سبيستي الصينيه امدت مجموعه
عبر الاقمار الصناعيه يذكر انه في الاسبوع
الماضي فرضت الولايات المتحده عقوبات على
شركه سبيستي بسبب علاقاتها مع فاجنر كما
استهدفت العقوبات فرعا للشركه في
لوكسمبورج
وقع الرئيس
مشاركه روسيا في معاهده الحد من الاسلحه
الاستراتيجيه ستارت كما اقر الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين بان العمل الماضي كان صعبا
مشيرا الى ان وكالات الامن الروسيه نجحت
في احباط مخططات ارهابيه تستهدف الامن
القومي الروسي
العام 2022 كان عاما صعبا في مواجهه
الارهاب قمتم بحمايه حدود روسيا واحباط
المخططات التي تستهدف امنا القومي جميعنا
نعرف ان تستخدم اساليب ارهابيه ولها تاريخ
طويل في ذلك اشكر كل القاده والجنود الذين
يعملون في الصفوف الاماميه ووجهوا ضربات
قاسمه للعدو
يواجه النت مشاهدينا ازمه كبيره تتمثل
بانتاج الاسلحه بعد ان احرقت الحرب في
اوكرانيا العتاده الغربي بمعدلات لم
يتصورها الغرب وفق صحيه صحيفه
التي اعتبرت ان الدول الغربيه تاخرت كثيرا
باعاده بناء صناعتها الدفاعيه وحرب
اوكرانيا شكلت صدمه وجلس انذار للقاده
الاوروبيين واستطاعوا خطر نشوب صراع مع
الصين ايضا دولونيناتو تحاول الان جاهده
لاعاده تحريك سوق تصنيع الاسلحه لمسانده
اوكرانيا لكن هذا الامر يتطلب سنوات من
العمل وميزانيه كبيره لتلبيه الحاجه على
الارض هذا الامر اكده امين عام حلف الناتو
معتبرا ان تصنيع الاسلحه يحتاج الى عقود
من العمل ويجب بذل المزيد من الجهد في هذا
الاطار وقبل ذلك كشف استوتنبرغ اتفاقا على
ان اوكرانيا ستصبح عضوا في الناتو على
المدى البعيد
اتفق اعضاء حلف شمال الاطلسي على ان
اوكرانيا ستصبح عضوا في تحالفنا ولكن في
نفس الوقت هذا يعد منظورا طويل المدى
الموضوع الان هو ضمان ان تعود اوكرانيا
دوله مستقله وذات سياده وبالتالي نحن
بحاجه لدعم اوكرانيا
في التاسعه هذا المساء سنتربى بعد قليل
بعد الزلزال وفاه شخصين واصابه اكثر من
500 شخص بالكوليرا شمال غرب سوريا
[موسيقى]
وحملت حملتي طائرات هليكوبتر
مائيتين كما نتابع في هذه الصوره اما
الجزء الثاني سيكون محاكاه لغز مباشر كما
نتابع تحاول هذه القوات الفرنسيه صده عبر
مشاركه 10 او 12 الف رجل على جبهه بطول 50
كيلومتر وعمق 200 كيلومتر مع تعبئه جميع
موارد الجيش ماذا سيجري خلال هذه العمليه
سيتم اجراء عمليه انزال برمائي كما نتابع
هنا ل 700 جندي و150 مركبه على ساحل البحر
المتوسط ومشاهدينا يعود تاريخ اخر عمليه
بهذا الحجم في ظروف حقيقيه الى عمليه
سيرفال في مالي عام
2012 عندما استولى الجنود الفرنسيون عندما
استولوا على مدينه تومباكتو
[موسيقى]
الى سوريا الان حيث قالت الخوه البيضاء ان
شخصين لقيا حتفهما في تفشن للكوليرا في
عقب الزلزال في الشمال الغربي ليرتفع عدد
ضحايا الكوليرا الى 22 شخصا واوضحت الخوذ
البيضاء ان هناك
568 مصابا بالكولر جراء دمار البنيه
التحتيه وخطوط المياه والصرف الصحي بعد
الزلزال
قال المبعوث الامي الى سوريا انه طلب
الجميع بعدم تسييس المساعدات الانسانيه
وتوفير الموارد العاجله وضروره ازاله
العراقل امامها لانقاذ السوريين
المحتجين
دعما للاستجابه الانسانيه حثيت الجميع على
عدم تسييس الاستجابه الانسانيه هذا يعني
الوصول هذا ليس الوقت للعب لعبه السياسه
في ليس على المساعده العابره للخطوط ولا
العابره للحدود هذا يعني توفير الموارد
التبرع بسرعه وبكرر لسوريا للتخلص من
الجميل على العراقيل التي تعيق وصول
الاغاثه للسوريين في المناطق المتاثره
وهذا يعني الهدوء ايضا هذا ليس وقت اتخاذ
التدابير عسكريه او عنيفه
[موسيقى]
الى الشان الايراني الان حيث تعاقب بعض
المناطق التي خرجت فيها الاحتياجات بخناق
اقتصادي شديد تفرضه قوات الامن على السكان
وفقا لمصادر حقوقيه ايرانيه من بينها
مناطق كرديه وبلوشيه واذريه لتتحول
احتياجات الايرانيين الاساسيه احلاما هذا
غير سوء الاداره والفساد والعقوبات التي
فاقمت الوضع الاقتصادي والمعيشي في ايران
وبالتالي ارتفع معدل التضخم السنوي الى
اكثر من 50% وفقدت العمله الايرانيه ما
يقرب من 45% من قيمتها منذ اندلاع
الاحتجاجات في اعقاب مقتل مهسى امينه
[موسيقى]
بوسط ايران ونقل بعضهن الى المستشفى لوقت
قصير وزاره الصحه قالت الاحد ان بعض
الافراد يسعون عبر ذلك الى اغلاق كل
المدارس وخصوصا مدارس الفتيات على غرار
طبعا ما تفعله طالبان في افغانستان هذه
القضيه اثارت غضبا كبيرا داخليا في ايران
كما ندد البعض بصمت السلطات عن العدد
المتزايد من المدارس التي شهدت هذه
الظاهره
[موسيقى]
كل عمرها
ينضم الينا من الرياض صالح حميده الباحث
في الشان الايراني صالح اهلا بك معنا هناك
موضوعان نريد ان نناقشهما اولا موضوع
العقاب الذي تفرضه ايران على المناطق التي
تخرج بمظاهرات او احتياجات ماذا لدينا من
تفاصيل حول هذا الامر باي ما هي طبيعه هذا
العقاب
يعني بطبيعه الحال هي مناطق بلوشستان
وكردستان
كانتا ولا تزالا في مقدمه
الاحتجاجات في ايران كما نعلم هاتين
المنطقتين تتميزان بانهما مواطن الاقليه
السنيه في ايران وتشكو من اضطهاد مزدوج
عرقي وديني
بالاضافه الى سائر التمييز والحرمان التي
الذي يمارس ضد كل الايرانيين لكن هذه
المناطق تعد من الافقر في ايران خاصه
والكثير من المواطنين كانوا يعتاشون على
بيع الوقود عبر الحدود مع باكستان
وافغانستان مع الاحتجاجات منذ خمسه اشهر
قامت السلطات بتشديد القبضه الامنيه
وبالتالي اصبحت حركه هؤلاء الناس الذين
يحاولون المتاجر بالوقود او البضائع عبر
الحدود اصعب بكثير في كردستان كذلك حيث ان
الناس الكثير من العمال
الذي يسمون كلب او العتالين اعطاشون عبر
نقل البضائع بالكردستان الايراني الى
كردستان العراق مع عسكره هذه المناطق
تحولت حياه الناس الى جحيم هناك اساسا هي
المناطق لا تنعم بالتنميه فيها حرمان فيها
انتشار للمخدرات والبطاله وهذه الممارسات
من قبل النظام وفي ظل هذه الاوضاع التي
سجلت العمله
تاريخيا حيث الدولار الان اصبح 60 الف
تومان بعدما كان قبل الاحتجاجات 25 الف
ضاعف من معاناه المواطنين الاسعار تضاعفا
بالنسبه للملف الثاني وهو موضوع ظاهره
تصميم البنات ماذا لدينا من تفاصيل من
وراء هذه الظاهره لماذا يتم تصميم
الطالبات والفتيات وهن في عمر صغير يعني
هناك مدارس بعمر العشره سنوات الفتيات
فيها
[موسيقى]
كبيره في الداخل واعتبرها الكثير انها في
اطار
الانتقام من حركه المراه الحياه الحريه
التي انطلقت من كردستان وانتشرت الى كل
مناطق ايران تاتي ضمن سلسله الترهيب
الاعدامات والان هناك اصدار احكام اعدام
وحمله اعتقالات بداتها السلطات ضد
الناشطين ضد كل من تعتبره انه له يد
بتحريك المظاهرات خاصه وانه يران تقترب من
عيد النوروز بعد حوالي 20 يوم
والناس
يقولون اهتماما كبيرا بهذا لكن
المائده الايرانيه فارغه هناك
فقر هناك غلاء فاحش للاسعار وليس لدى
السلطات سواء الحل الامر لهذا ما سيررشح
بالمزيد من المظاهرات والاحتجاجات خاصه
قبل فتره النوروز وبعد هذا ما يتوقعه
الكثير من المراقبه
من الرياض
في خبر متعلق ايضا بايران كشفت الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه عن جزئيات تيرانيوم
مخصصه في ايران تقل النقاوتها عن 90% وهي
نسبه كافيه لصنع سلاح نووي وقالت الوكاله
ان ايران ارجعت هذه النسبه الى امكانيه
حدوث خلل في عمليه التخصيب الا ان الوكاله
انتقدت ايران لعدم الشفافيه في السماح
بمراقبه منشاتها النبويه وكاله الطاقه
الذريه اكدت ان مخزون ايران من اليورانيوم
المخصب بنسب مختلفه زاد بنحو 87 كيلوغراما
منذ اخر تقرير فصلي ليصل الى اكثر من
3760 كيلو جراما وافادت الوكاله ان هذا
المخزون يتجاوز السقف المسموح به لايران
باكثر من ثمانيه عشره مره كما اضافت
الوكاله ان ايران لديها 42 كلغ من
اليورانيوم المخصب بنسبه 60% وهو يحتاج
لتعزيز بسيط لانتاج سلاح نووي
لدورها اعربت وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه
انا لينا عن قلقها من القصائد النوويه
الايراني في تخصيب اليورانيوم داعيه الى
منع ايران من امتلاك قنبله نوويه
الايراني وبشان التقارير الاخيره عن تخصيب
اليورانيوم المرتفع للغايه لا يوجد مبرر
مدني معقول لمثل هذا التخصيب المرتفع يجب
منع ايران من امتلاك قنبله نوويه
[موسيقى]
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه التابعه لحركه
طالبان ان 80 افغانيا ضمن قتل حادث تحطم
قارب قباله صباح الايطاليا وذكرت السلطات
الايطاليه ومنقذون ان 64 مهاجرا على الاقل
او حتفهم في الحادث بينما نجا 80 اخرون
لكن يعتقد انه هناك المزيد في عداد
المفقودين بناء على تقديرات الناجين الذين
قالوا انما يصلوا الى 200 شخصا كانوا على
متن هذا القارب
في التاسع هذا المساء نتابع بعد قليل
بعد تقارير عن حالات وفاه جراء المجاعه
زعيم كوريا الشماليه يغير سياسه الانتاج
الزراعي في بلاده
[موسيقى]
بعد اشهر من المفاوضات السريه نشرت
المملكه المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي
نستفاقهما الجديد لتحسين ترتيبات ما بعد
خروج بريطانيا من الاتحاد الاوروبي
لايرلندا الشماليه الاتفاق الذي يطلق عليه
اطار
حددت طرقا لتسهيل عمل ما يسمى ببروتوكول
ايرلندا الشماليه باكثر من 100 صفحه اطار
العمل الجديد يبقي مقاطعه ايرلندا
الشماليه في السوق الاوروبيه الموحده وضمن
الاتحاد الجمركي للتكتل وينص على اجراء
تفتيش للسلع المتجهه من بقيه انحاء
المملكه المتحده الى ايرلندا الشماليه
طبعا كما يهدف هذا الاطار الجديد الى
تحسين اداء البروتوكول في عده مجالات
رئيسيه سنستعرض ابرزها مثلا سيتم تقسيم
البضائع القادمه من بريطانيا الى ايرلندا
الشماليه سيتم تقسيمها الى فئتين الفئه
الاولى المتجهه الى ايرلندا الشماليه
ستكون بالم الاخضر وتلك المتجهه الى
ايرلندا والسوق الموحده للاتحاد الاوروبي
ستكون بالممر الاحمر الاتحاد الاوروبي كشف
ايضا ان الشركات التي تسجل في مخطط تاجر
موثوق به وتستخدم ايضا الممر الاخضر سيكون
لديها تخفيض غير مسبوق في الاوراق
الجمركيه ايضا سيتعين على البضائع
الموجوده في الممر ان تمر عبر فحوصات
الجمارك والغذاء والصحه ودائما للتدقيق
الكامل اما بالنسبه للاغذيه الزراعيه
فسيقبل الاتحاد الاوروبي معايير الصحه
العامه في المملكه المتحده ما يعني انه
سيتم السماح للحوم الطازجه وغيرها من
السلع بدخول ايرلندا الشماليه بعد ان يوضع
عليها ملصقات ليس للاتحاد الاوروبي ومع
ادخال الملصقات من الان وحتى عام 20 25
ستنخفض نسبه الشح نات الخاضعه للتحقق من
الهويه
ستنخفض الى 5% كما نتابع هنا وبالتالي
ستكون الاجراءات اقل تعقيدا واكثر سهوله
على الناس وايضا على الشركه
[موسيقى]
متابعه للموضوع من لندن تنضم الينا مراسله
العربيه كارينا كامل كارينا اهلا بك معنا
ما الذي ميز هذا الاتفاق حتى تم القبول به
الان من كافه الاطراف بعد كل الجدل الذي
حصل عليه في السنوات الماضيه
يعني حقيقه هو انجاز لريشي سونك وانجاز
للحزب الحاكم فعليا بعد كل هذه السنوات
وطال انتظار هذا الاتفاق الذي حل معدله
ايرندا الشماليه يعني السبب وراء ربما
التقبل للاحزاب والاطراف المختلفه هو ان
هذا الاتفاق المطروح يحل مشكله او معضله
اللاندا الشماليه التي كانت بموجب التي
فوق السابق ايرندا الشماليه خاضعه لقواعد
اوروبيه وبالتالي احكام محكمه العدل
الاوروبيه رغم انه ايرلندا الشماليه بطبع
جزء من المملكه المتحده وبالطبع البعض راى
انه هذا الموقف غير مقبول لانه يمس سياده
ايرلندا الشماليه وسياده المملكه المتحده
باكملها كيف حدث ذلك ما الذي يميز هذا
الاتفاق ثلاثه نقاط اساسيه بكل بساطه هذه
الممرات المختلفه ممر لونه اخضر للبضائع
المتجهه من بريطانيا العظمى وتنتهي او
ينتهي مسارها في ايرلندا الشماليه هذا
الممر اخضر مفتوح من دون اي تدقيقات
جمركيه من دون اي مستندات سهوله الحركه
بشكل سلس وبشكل سريع وممر احمر للبضائع
المتوجهه من بريطانيا العظمى او مسارها
ينتهي فيه دوله ايرلندا طبعا جزء من
الاتحاد الاوروبي هذا الخط وهذا الممر
للبضاعه سيكون فيه تدقيقات جمركيه طبيعيه
ولكن بعض التسهيلات متعلقه بالديتا شارينج
او تبادلا المعلومات الرقميه فهذا اولا
هذه الممرات التي تسهل حركه البضائع وتزيل
كل التدقيقات ما بين انحاء المملكه
المتحده المختلفه ثانيا تقليص عدد او كميه
القواعد التي هي مفروده او الساريه داخل
اللاندا الشماليه وبالتالي دور محكمه
العدل الاوروبيه ايضا سيكون مقلص او سيكون
اقل داخل ايرلندا الشماليه ثالثا وربما
هذه هي نقطه الاهم والتي قد تكون سبب قبول
الاحزاب في ايرلندا الشماليه لهذا الاتفاق
هو حق الاعتراض الستور
الحكومه المحليه في ايرلندا الشماليه هي
معلقه حاليا بسبب خلافات حول هذا
البروتوكول ولكن الامل الان انه سيتم يعني
اعاده تكوين المجلس من جديد لدى هذا
المجلس حق الاعتراض اذا ما ادخلت اوروبا
اي قواعد يعترض عليها هذا المجلس بعيدا عن
هذا الاتفاق وكما ذكرت في بدايه
حديثك بانه هذا يعتبر انجاز للحزب الحاكم
ولريشي سوناك الان كيف سيستفيد ريشيسوناك
والحزب الحاكم سياسيا من هكذا اتفاق
يعني هذا الاتفاق في غايه الاهميه شخصيا
وبالطبع للحزب المحافظ اولا ريشيسونك اذا
ما فعليا انجز هذا الاتفاق وهنا فقط تذكير
انه نحن بانتظار الموافقه الرسميه من حزب
الدي يوبي من حزب شنفين والاحزاب المختلفه
مع كل الاحزاب المختلفه في محاوله
لاقناعهم بقبول هذا الاتفاق ونحن ننتظر
الاجابه الرسميه من هذه الاطراف وثانيا
اليوم الليله يجتمع مع كل الاطراف
المختلفه في الحزب المحافظ ايضا في محاوله
لاقناعهم بقبول هذا الاتفاق واذا فعلها
فعليا
وتمكن من الحصول على كل هذه الموافقات
والقبول من الاطراف المختلفه سيكون فعليا
انجاز تاريخي لانه سيكون فعل ما لم يتمكن
من تحقيقه بولس جونسون الذي طبعا معروف
بانه هو الذي انجز البراكزيت نفسه فهذا
اولا واكيد انتصار كبير جدا داخل الحزبه
المحافظ ولكن الكل يعرف انه وضع الحزب
المحافظ يعني وضع حرج جدا داخل المعادله
السياسيه في بريطانيا اخر استطلاع مثلا
يظهر تقدم الحزب العمالي بما بين 28 و29
نقطه يعني مقابل الحزب المحافظ واذا ما
يعني تجسد ذلك على ارض الواقع في انتخابات
اليوم هو يعني انتصار ساحق للحزب العمالي
ونحن نعرف ان موعد الانتخابات القادمه كحد
اقصى بحسب الجدول الحالي المفروض من قبل
البرلمان اقصى موعد الانتخابات القادمه
يناير 25 يعني بعد تقريبا عام او او عام
ونصف من الان
الوقت ضيق جدا لريشيسونك لاقناع الشعب
البريطاني انه الحزب المحافظ قادر فعليا
على تحسين الاوضاع الاقتصاديه وانجاز بشكل
ايجابي لانه حتى ساعه طبعا ميسونه الكل
يعرف نحن نتحدث ربما عن سلبيات البرازيت
ولم يشعل المواطن بعد باي ايجابيات من هذا
الاتفاق حتى الساعه وطبعا اخيرا الوضع
الاقتصادي في غايه السلبيه الامل طبعا انه
هذا سيصب في مصلحه النشاط الاقت صادي
وسيبدا المواطن ان يشعر بتغير في حياته
والامل طبعا نحن ننتظر الاستطلاعات التي
يعني ستتم ربما في الايام القادمه اذا كان
هناك تحسن في حدود الحزب المحافظ في
الاستطلاعات هذا سيكون ابرز دليل على اثر
هذا الاتفاق على مصير الحزب المحافظ
المستقبل اشكرك على كل هذه المعلومات على
كل هذه التفاصيل كارينا كامل مراسلات
العربيه من لندن
[موسيقى]
تعاني من ازمه في الغذاء وتراجع في مجال
الزراعه وذلك في ظل تهديدات بمواجهه شبح
المجاعات التي مرت بها كوريا الشماليه في
تسعينيات القرن الماضي وهو الامر الذي دفع
حزب العمال الحاكم لتخصيص اجتماعه السنوي
لبحث الازمه على مدار يومين
تتخبط يمينا ويسارا في مواجهه معضله نقص
الغذاء تمر السنوات والخطر قائم هذا العام
البحث عن مخرج للازمه بدا بتصفيق حاد
لمسؤوليها في اجتماع قاده حزب العمال
الحاكم
اما زعيمها فيبقيه انهماكه في تطوير
ترسانته النوويه بعيدا عن افواه تتضور
جوان
اجتماع جاء قبل موعده المقرر في كل عام
لبحث ازمه الزراعه وقبل التطرق لتفاقمها
كانت الاولويه للتحدث عن انجازات العام
المنصرم لثوره الريفيه لم تتحقق بعد
جرس الانذار بازمه زراعيه وغذائيه يستمع
له كيم جونغ اون منذ فتره فلم يمر سوى
شهرين فقط على جلسه سابقه للهدف ذاته
وفي بلد يحتاج لمصارحه مع مزارعه بسبل
الخروج من الازمه اعلنت وكاله الانباء
الكوريه الشماليه ان المسؤولين وافقوا
بالاجماع على بنود جدول الاعمال وامر
بتغيير جذري لقطاع الزراعه دون الافصاح عن
المزيد
اما الجاره الجنوبيه
فقد درت نسبه عجز في الحبوب في كوريا
الشماليه بنحو مليون طن اي ما يقرب من 20%
من حاجتها السنويه ووفقا لخبراء فان نقص
الغذاء الحالي هو الاسوا منذ تولي كيم
جونغ اون السلطه في عام 2011
وزاره التوحيد في كوريا الجنوبيه افادت
ايضا بالابلاغ عن وفيات بسبب الجوع في بلد
يخضع العقوبات المتعدده بسبب برامج
الاسلحه الى جانب مواجهه مخاوفه من تكرار
كوارث طبيعيه قد تؤدي الى مجاعات كسابقتها
في تسعينيات القرن الماضي
علي السمان العربيه
[موسيقى]
مخاوف وامنيات جديه بدا يشكلها تطبيق تيك
توك على الغرب وفق تصريحاته مسؤولين ولذلك
كان لابد من خطوات سريعه لتجنب الاختراقات
الامنيه حيث وافق البرلمان الاوروبي على
حظر تطبيق الصيني على اجهزه موظفيه اما
البيت الابيض سبقه في هذه الخطوه حين امهل
جميع الوكالات الفيدراليه الامريكيه 30
يوما لازاله تطبيق تيك توك من جميع
الاجهزه الحكوميه ويخدع تطبيق الصيني لذات
الاجراء في كندا
المواجهه بين واشنطن لم تعد تقتصر على
السياسه والاقتصاد بل امتدت الى وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي لا تيك توك بعد الان في
جميع الاجهزه الحكوميه الامريكيه البيت
الابيض يتخذ القرار بعد ان اخضع الموقع
الصيني للتدقيق في ظل وجود مخاوف امنيه 30
يوما حيز زمني امام الوكالات الفيدراليه
لحظر التطبيق على هواتفها واجهزتها بسبب
مخاطر على الامن القومي الامريكي مع منع
الاتصال عبر الانترنت بين هذه الاجهزه
والتطبيق قلق كبير يساور الولايات المتحده
من استغلال الصين للتطبيق للحصول على
بيانات المستخدمين الخاصه او لمحاوله نشر
معلومات مضلله او تقارير لصالح بيكين
الى جانب المخاوف الامنيه اتهامات متزايده
للمنصه تقول انها تستخدم خوارزميات تراقب
سلوكيات متصفحها ومن خلال ذلك تعتمد على
اسلوبين داخل الصين عبر التركيز على
المحتوى الجاد والثقافي وخارجها من خلال
تشجيع المحتوى الترفيهي القرار الامريكي
ياتي بوعيده قرار مماثل اصدرته الحكومه
الكنديه وحضرت وفقه تنزيل التطبيق على
الهواتف والاجهزه الالكترونيه التابعه لها
وكذلك فعلت المفوضيه الاوروبيه الاسبوع
الماضي الخارجيه الصينيه رفضت قرار البيت
الابيض قائله ان الولايات المتحده تقمع
الشركات الاجنبيه وتتجاوز مفهوم الامن
القومي
يعارض بشده للنهج الخاطئه للجانب الامريكي
والمتمثله في ارهاق مفهوم الامن القومي
واساءه استخدام القوه الوطنيه وقمع شركات
البلدان الاخرى بشكل غير منطقي تيك توك
يحظى بشعبيه كبيره ويستخدمه ثلثا
المراهقين في الولايات المتحده غير ان
المخاوف تتزايد من امكانيه استخدامه من
بيكين للتجسس على واشنطن بلال البجدين
العربيه
[موسيقى]
دفع تقنيه
لحشد فريق لتطوير منافس جديد بوجه هذا
التطبيق الذكي رابط المحادثه النصيه الذي
طورته شركه طبعا والذي يمكنك من خلاله
صياغه نصوص برمجيه هو اسمه سواء النثر او
حتى الشعر وغيرها وصل عدد مستخدمي في وقت
قصير الى اكثر من مليونين الامر الذي دفع
بعلم ماسك الى التحرك والتواصل مع باحثين
في الذكاء الاصطناعي خلال الاسابيع
الاخيره من اجل تاسيس مختبر ابحاث جديد
لتطوير بديل لتشات لكن المشروعه لا يزال
في مراحله الاولى والتي هنا ان ماس كان
شارك في تاسيس اوبنال في وادي السيليكون
عام 2015 ولكن باعتبارها شركه ناشئه غير
هادفه للرباح ترك مجلس ادارتها عام 2018
واليوم يبدو انه نادم على قراره واعتبر ان
تشات
تقنيه جيده جدا بشكل مخيف بحسب وصفه
[موسيقى]
ختام نذكر بعناوين التاسعه هذا المساء
بمقابله خاصه للعربيه رئيس الوزراء
الاوكراني يطالب بضغط على ايراني منعها من
امداد روسيا بالمسيارات
خوفا من نقص ترسانتها العسكريه جيوش
اوروبيه ترفض ارسال اليوفارد لاوكرانيا
وظاهره مخيفه في مدارس البنات بايران
هجمات وتسميم متعمده للطالبات والصحه تكشف
هناك من يريد حاضره تعليم الفتيات
وعلى غرار كندا وامريكا البرلمان الاوروبي
يحضر تطبيق تيك توك على هواتف موظفه خوفا
من الاختراق
الاخبار على العربيه لا تنتهي نتابع ايضا
ملفات جديده مع 360 وطاهر ما هي ملفاتك
اليوم حضورك يزداد تالقا بالبن اللي
لابستيه العربيه 20 عاما شكرا راح نضل
نلبسه اذا الله راد ليوم الجمعه ثلاثه
ثلاثه حيث التغطيه المكثفه لعيد العربيه
نحن سنتحدث عن سعي واشنطن لضرب نفوذ روسيا
في اسيا الوسطى وكذلك عن تجديد الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه رصد جزيئات يورنيوم
قد يعني تصل الى اقل من 90 بالمئه بقليل
مع تمسك طهران بروايتها فارجوا ان تكوني
معا